Herkese
merhabalar ben
oan 11 sını sını öğrencisiyim Diyarbakır
doğumluyum bugün anlatacaklar asında bir
Diyarbakırlı doğlu olmdan
dolayı İnsanoğlu olduğundan beri her
zaman bir savaş vardı para için olabilir
Şöhret için olabilir ya da Toprak için
olabilir oldem değ ama heram bir savaş
vardı ve bu savaşlarda milyonlarca
düğümlenen hayat vard Ben de bugün size
bu savaşlardan sade
birinden
hağ gibi saa her yerde variz
gin yok zaten yaşam şans Old ülkemizde
bir savaş var yı sü p
sa satılan roketler falan var ben size
bugün işte halihazırda devam eden
Diyarbakır sur'daki
çatışmalardan etkilenen ü tane hayattan
bahsedeceğim
Eee Tabii ki de şimdi birçok savaş var
dedik Hep vardı dedik hala devam ediyor
dedik ve ben burada size bütün savaşları
anlatmayacağım zaten burada önemli olan
bütün savaşları anlamak onları kavramak
değil Benim buradaki amacım savaşların
ne kadar gereksiz ve saçma olduğunu
zor
haak yakınlıkta oturan Efe üçüncüsü de
ayda bir 2 ayda bir Diyarbakır devine
giden ben birinci örneğimiz başlayalım
Ahmet Bey dediğim gibi be çocuğuyla
eşiyle surda taştan yapılma derme çatma
bir yerde yaşıyor zaten Sur genel olarak
fakir bir bölge kendisi çarşıda bakır
işleyip satıyor bakır çarşısında ve ayda
yaklaşık 600 700 liradan fazla bir
gelere sahip
değil çatışmaya başladığımda bu savaş
dediğim şey başladığımda ilk olarak bir
haftalık bir sokağa çıkma yasağı ilan
edildi ve insanlar bir hafta evinde
kalmak zorunda kaldılar Dediğim gibi
Ahmet Bey'in çok parası yok evine başka
bir gelir kaynağı da yok Dolayısıyla
Aslında evinde Çok da fazla erzağı yok
ya bir şekilde Ahmet Beyi Belki bir gün
belki ik gün yeteceği yemek de 7 kişi
bir hafta geçirmeye çalıştı bunun
sonrasında 7 günden sonra yarım günlük
bir Ar verildi sokağa çıkma esa bunun
asıl sebebi insanların yaşadığı yerden
başka bir yere gitmesi Çünkü daha kolay
Savaşı bir şekilde fakat Ahmet Bey'in
evini taşıması gerekiyordu yeni bir eve
ihtiyacı vardı ama 600 700 lir kazanan
bir insandan ki çatışmalardan dolayı
artık bir işi de yok artık onu da
kazanamıyor yeni bir ev almasını ev
tutmasını Ya da evini taşıyabilmesi
bekleyemezsiniz ki Ahmet Bey de bunu
yapamadı ne evini
soken sonuç
ih kac
elimize
h
bular i
şeyler Bunları
yapak
ha ne oldu diye sordum bana dedi ki
evlerini taşıyan insanlar gördüm dedi
okuldan çıktığımda ve sadece bir
bohçayla Sadece elinde bir salça kutusu
turşu kutusu ve küçük bir sopayla evini
taşıyan insanları gördüm dedi o
fakirliği o zorluğu gördüm dedi ve
oturup ağladım dedi gerçekten de orada
oturup Ağlamış
yani ve sonra işte konuşmaya devam ettik
falan genel olarak böyle konuştuk Sonra
Dersler nasıl diye sordum Ne dersi dedi
ders mi işleye biliyoruz dedi
bir
dah sesler
işiyoruz sesleriz
bizizi gi
adam sür eğ
sarıyoruz
ama biz asında bu adamdan huzur bir
yaşam sürmesini
bekleyemeyiz her gün penceresinden
baktığında Savaşı gören ölümü gören
ölümün sesini duy bir insandan biz böyle
bir şey
bekle Buna ek
olar yağı bin adet Meri
saı As evak
üzere ve nasıl bir psikolojide olursunuz
hala ders çalışabilir misiniz hala
içinizi rahat uyuyabilir misiniz Tabii
ki de bunları yapabiliyor değil Ve
bunları bekleme hakkımız olduğunu da
düşünmüyorum son olarak kendime geçeyim
Eee size Dediğim gibi ben ayda bir ya da
2 ayda bir bir hafta olarak eve
gidiyorum maksimum bir hafta
kalıyorum ilk gittiğimde bu savaşlar
Savaş başladıktan sonra ilk gittiğimde
işte ucaklar indim Eve gittim Falan
akşam ü
s yerine alamıyor Yani hiçbir zaman biz
Savaş ortamına gidene kadar Aslında
savaşın nasıl bir şey olduğunu
anlayamıyoruz çünkü televizyonda
gördüğünüz sosyal medyada gördüğünüz
bütün her şey sayılardan ibaret yani
spada görüyorsunuz 10 İnsan işte 10 kişi
yaşamını yitirdi ama biz bunu sayılara
döktüğümüzde Aslında ölümleri bir nebze
olsa yumuşatıyor ve içimizi rahatlatıyor
Ama siz savaş alanında olup bunu
gördüğünüzde bunu duyduğunuzda gerçekten
ölümde burun burun olduğunuzu
hissediyorsunuz ve
met
yiü dah olduz bir
yiyor üme kar YS her
ığı
iin
buı
h iç burasına saplanmış ver kafatasından
girememiş Neyse
ki ve o insan önemli değil aslında
herhangi bir insan ama o insan anneniz
de olabilirdi Yani benim annem de
olabilirdi Dolayısıyla ben bu sefer
kendi kendimi başta ailemi sonra
arkadaşlarımı düşünmeye başlıyorum acaba
bunlar başına bugün bir şey geldi mi
acaba yarın bir şey olacak mı ya da
sonraki gün bu savaş zaman BK bunların
hepsini düşünmeye başlıyorsunuz ve
hiçbir zaman rahat uyuyamıyorsun ister
orada olun ister buraya gelin Ben bugün
Dün yarın her zaman insanlar Acaba bir
şey olduğun düşüncesiyle yaşım Son 3 Gün
içinde diyarbak sadece Diyarbakır'da
tane bomba patladı Mesela işte ben
insanları Aradım abi bir şeyiniz var
falan iyi misiniz diy ve Aslında her
günüm böyle geçiyor orası sadece
diyarbak olduğu için sadece diyarbak
başka yerlerde de savaş var ama Han
sevdiklerim orada olduğu için her günüm
onları düşünerek geçiyor acaba Yarın bir
şey olacak güzel bugün bir şey olmadı
herkesinde diye düşünüyorum ama bu
düşünce size her zaman Huzurlu bir hayat
yaşamaktan uzak tutuyor çünkü hiçb zaman
Emin olamıyorsunuz her zaman ölümden
korkuyorsunuz ve dediğim gibi ölümden
ölümün gelmesinden korkan bir ins
huzurlu Hayat
bekleyiniz yaşamanın amacı Aslında
hayatta kalmak başka bir
şey son olarak Umar Bugün size bir
şeyler kabilmi
bugün bütün savaşlardan sadece birinden
ü tane küçücük örnek verdim üstek
bunların hiçbiri savaşta ölen ya da yar
alan insanlardan insanlar değiller ve
düşünün bunlar bile bu kadar etkilenmiş
Ken orada diğer insanlar ne halde umarım
dediğim gibi Umarım bir nebze savaşa
bakışınızı değiştirebilmek bugünkü
amacım buydu ve konuşmada ın son bir
sözüyle bitirmek istiyorum Savaş ne işe
yarar Tabii ki de hiçbir şey teşekkür
ederim
oh